سنضع الابعاد العسكريه جانبا وهناك كارثه
انسانيه وباياره فقط تدمير خزان نوفا
كاخوكا والسبب 18 كيلومترا مكعبا من
المياه دمرت معها كل ما يوجد على ضفاف نهر
النيبر الجهه الواقعه تحت السيطره الروسيه
كانت الاكثر تاثرا اضافه الى انسحاب
الجيشين اضطره سكان اربعين بلده النزوح
نحو مناطق اكثر امانا جهود الجيشين ذهبت
هباء بعد ان جرفت المياه الالغام وهدمت
الخنادق والتحصينات الحصار المياه وجفاف
الاوحال بعد اسابيع سيعيد الجبهه الى نقطه
الصفر
رغم ذلك موسكو وكيف تبادلتها الاتهامات
بخصوص المسؤوله عن تفجير سد نوفا والسبب
هو تضارب المعلومات حول الطريقه التي
استهدف بها السد الروايه الروسيات تتحدث
عن صاروخ ستورب شادو البريطاني استهدف
جدار السد بشكل مباشر مما تسبب في دمار
جزء هام كان كافيا لتسرب المياه لكن السد
عباره عن كتله اسمنتيه متماسكه ولا يستطيع
صاروخ واحد مهما كانت قوته تدمير السد
والتسبب في ضرر مماثل وهنا قدمت اوكرانيا
روايتها البديله القوات الروسيه وخوفا من
تقدم اوكرانيا عبر نهر دنيبر قامت بوضع
متفجرات والغام في اماكن محدده لضمان
العمليه وهنا نجحت موسكو في ربح هدنه قد
تمتد لاسابيع في جبهه خرسون لكن جهات
محايده اعطت روايه اخرى اكثر واقعيه
يعاني اصلا من تسريب المياه بسبب تعرضه
للاستهداف مرات عند اما الضربه فقد اجهزت
على هيكله الذي لم يصمد امام قوه دفع
المياه لكن بغض النظر عن المسؤول التفجير
حدث بالفعل الاخطر فيه الكارثه البيئيه
المرتقبه الضربه لم تدمر السده وحده بل
ايضا محطه توليد الطاقه المرافقه امر تسبب
في تسرب 150 طنا من النفط الى النهر ضربه
موجعه للزراعه خرسون بالطبع تمتد
تداعياتها للحياه البحريه في البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات